pop star never stopped never stopping
stars Andy Samberg as Connor for real
the biggest pop sensation of this movies
universe he's super successful everyone
loves him he can get into any club
anywhere he's rich as hell and he's an
idiot which leads him to make some
horrible choices while writing terrible
music which tanks his career and this is
a satirical look at what it's like to be
a pop star and it's done in a
documentary style complete with
interviews from real-life musicians and
producers in the music industry and it's
done to make it seem as if you are
watching someone's documentary as its
unfolding which is a clever idea and for
the most part I would say that idea
works I like Andy Samberg I think he's
more talented than people give him
credit for he's very funny he's very
likable and in past films like Celeste
and Jesse forever he has shown himself
to be a fine actor I liked him in this
film I think he really put the sights on
the pop music industry and there are
certain things about it that are very
much so reminiscent of Justin Bieber's
life from the weird pets to something
involving Anne Frank and you can tell
that he's definitely pay reading that a
little bit and some of the jokes work
really well in particular the songs if
you're easily offended you're going to
be offended but the point of it is is
that this guy is writing horrific aliy
offensive music because he thinks
everything he touches turns to gold even
though it clearly doesn't the songs are
definitely the best part but one thing
about this movie that really did
surprise me is how it starts to drag
after a while it does feel a bit tedious
certain gags that aren't funny go on and
on certain characters that weren't
really that entertaining or well fleshed
out continue to come back and continue
to come back but similar to a pop song
you might hear on the radio that you
think is catchy once or twice but over
and over again then five months later 67
thousand times of hearing Robin Thicke
and blurred lines it starts to grate on
your nerves after a while and there are
parts of this movie that are like that
it's about a character that's such an
imbecile that surrounds himself with
yes-men that it takes so long for him to
realize what's going on and for that
comeuppance to really happen to him that
arc that you want to see in a movie like
this and it takes so long to get to that
point even though the film is only 86
minutes long and that was surprising
because I actually thought it was more
like a
100 to 110 minutes and when I looked and
said 86 minutes I was like you're
kidding me I thought a lot longer than
that and in some ways I think that might
have to do with the documentary style if
your subject isn't interesting and they
don't find a way to make it feel
interesting documentaries can be one of
the most boring things to watch a great
documentary that you are invested in
that you want to learn about that you
feel as if you're emotionally attached
to it then that's some of the best
viewing you can possibly have but a
terrible documentary it'll put you right
to sleep
and since I didn't really care that much
about these fake characters even though
it's very satirical the documentary
aspect didn't always work because you're
examining something in a documentary
style that I just wasn't really that
interested in and that's probably
extremely pretentious way to view a
silly movie about a pop star in all
reality though this is just a pretty
harmless movie that takes some shots at
the pop industry sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't it's not as funny
as I think it thinks it is but the songs
are great I'm gonna give pop star never
stop never stopping a C+ so like I said
earlier I am teaming up with the highly
respected Full Sail University working
in the film industry is an exciting and
rewarding experience but if you don't
know how to get involved there aren't
quite sure what role you want to take on
Full Sail University can help you out
Full Sail offers film degrees on campus
and online that can really show you what
it's like to work on a film from start
to finish you even get to work hands-on
with the same equipment the
professionals use they offer an online
digital cinematography degree where you
can learn film basics with a modern
digital spin or maybe you already have
film experience and are ready to take
your skills to the next level Full Sail
grads have gone on to work on films like
Avengers age of Ultron minions Jurassic
world frozen and much more if you want
to find out more about that visit Full
Sail dot edu slash Chris stuckman thank
you so much to Full Sail University
that's amazing I've actually
legitimately looked into that University
before and I was impressed with
everything I saw and that's one of the
reasons I wanted to work with them
because I know a lot of my viewers are
interested in film just like I am so
guys check that out please Full Sail dot
edu slash Chris Stockman you guys are
the best look forward to my new office
tour because I have built a new film set
at my new place we haven't started
filming there obviously it's the same
old stuff but I'm excited to film in
there and I did something kind of fun
with the office tour if you ever seen
the movie Spring Breakers James Franco
gives one of the funniest most hilarious
performances I've ever seen from him and
I thought it'd be funny to kind of ape
that a little bit look forward to that's
going to be up very soon as well as a
review for Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
out of the shadows thank you guys as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes